it turns out that a hell of a lot of  people went to see Star Wars The Force  awakens on New Year's Day and as a  result the movie is continuing to break  a box-office records the latest  installment in the epic sci-fi franchise  has made an all-time domestic box office  record for Newsday by making 34.5  million dollars at the international box  office the force awakens made a figure  that was a tired and less impressive  than its us sales collecting 25 million  over the day globally to date the newest  star wars film has made an enormous 1.5  1,000,000,000 the movie has now  surpassed Harry Potter in the deathly  hallows part 2 and Avengers age of  Ultron to take the number 6 spot in the  all-time worldwide box office record  it's also expected to lap Furious 7 and  the first Avengers film to snag the  number four spot before too long let me  know in the comments if you're a star  Wars fan and stay tuned to gamespot for  all the latest